this is so hard who's your favorite  movie villain obviously Hitler  oh I'm gonna start like I thought you  meant like the worst  I thought you meant like the worst oh  you know who's a great villain oh what's  his name in Inglorious Bastards like the  head Nazi what's that actor's name the  the Kristoff Waltz with like the milk  scene and like I'd love a glass of your  delicious milk and just being that's a  good one everyone  only because I watched it recently so  that's in my mind also what's his name  not Cronus uh in Thor Ragnarok again I'm  representing it the bad guy that  actually wants to ethnic cleanse and  you're like part of you is like I kind  of see your point yeah